[Music]
and don't touch my food news don't
[ __ ] do it touch mom Joey doesn't
share food submitted by the hand of the
king of Joe Mallya Oh the Kings hand Oh
which one the left or the right
no like Tyrion position oh I don't know
a real cop damn I just want to always be
a thing I know oh it's so bad I think
that's one of the things i'ma do is make
a theme park Oh Jamal eeeh but you can't
do everything you want to do I know you
need a country for that can we just buy
an island and just [ __ ] disgusting
behavior by the owner of a Carl's jr.
franchise was caught on video oh [ __ ]
what was this person doing disgusting
behavior
Oh disgusting I thought they were
discussing I loved Carl's jr. because
they have lettuce wrap burgers you ask
me a lettuce I love fried chicken from
there no Betty we were having a
conversation about things you love Oh
disgusting is it cuz like I don't care
how dirty fast who it is
I know it's dirty mm-hmm so I don't care
well if it's like he's like fingerings
butthole and then sticky
it doesn't affect this to me yeah if I
don't throw up or have diarrhea it
tastes great because sometimes that
greasy hamburger does smell like Bo one
time I was eating a taco I remember from
where like Taco Bell or fast whatever
it's never talked about to get back
maybe del Taco I don't know
no don't know [ __ ] oh yeah yes yes but I
was eating a taco and I shot acid el
taco they're the only ones in this world
that would recognize who we are she's at
the peak of her story right now I love
del Taco it's time I do because you know
sometimes the shell get stuck I was a
pig and it was a chunk of hair chunk up
here I was like oh did I just eat like I
think I just ate a taco fools just like
chunks of hair and I want to [ __ ] kill
myself you know what I had that too at
Jack in a box in the Jack in a box taco
meat I was like in the hair was like it
looked like hair that someone just went
like cuz some of the [ __ ] get a
haircut in the in the kitchen and then
they put their haircut hair like in them
mm-hmm it was bombed though it was so
good it was so good oh maybe they were
just shaving while they're doing it you
know what's good about Carl's jr. there
though the Chris cut fries like I don't
even know why they waste their time
selling the regular fries cuz they taste
like [ __ ] I feel like I can't trust
anyone who orders regular fries from
Carl's jr. yeah or regular fries from
Jeff and bucks it's what's the point
yeah it's either curly fries or Chris
cut there's nothing else yeah you have
social problems and psychological
problems if you get the regular fries at
the and low IQ yeah you can't just like
that yeah and a bad credit score and
probably a criminal history so there's
this owner in Alberta Canada Canada oh
thank goodness that's Canadian Carl's
jr. yeah sorry
maybe Carl's jr. so he's a co franchisee
so he also owns it with someone else so
this dude his name is jack how ironic he
works for a jack-in-the-box season under
yes I was that's tough what a dickwad
yeah so Jack has the biggest probably
having Canada just battled the best
boots cuz they're so nice we don't have
anything else to [ __ ] fight about
yeah yeah so Jack he's been observed by
his employees and so this manager his
name is Andrew he's been trying to get
the other co franchisee to see how
disgusting Jack is cuz he's been he's
been handling food without gloves I
he'll pick up food from the floor and
put it back in and it's like it's so did
so jack is a co-owner franchisee yeah it
also sounds like he got trained out of
Chinese restaurant mm-hmm Jack Lee Jack
Webb is there footage yes Andrew he the
former manager he took this footage of
the security with his phone and so he
used this to go to the other of the
co-owner but the co-owner was just like
man it's fine so she was just so it's
hauled so he took this footage and he
went to the headquarters and he also
took it to the Canada Food Safety Group
and so they reviewed this and they found
they found that they he had captured ten
videos of serious food safety
regulations
odo infraction this is a good person it
is a good person unless he's taking away
the flavor I mean what was he doing I
was so bad did he like wipe his ass with
hamburger buns elbow-deep in a sauce and
barbecue sauce what what is he doing
though so right here he's mixing it with
his bare hey are you not supposed to do
that employees are looking at him like
what the hell so he actually hands him a
ladle and he says no what he keeps
stirring it
wait wait wait wait did he wash his
hands though because I mean sushi chefs
they use bare yeah why does he give
music his [ __ ] hands he's mixing
better but you know they do that I like
fine dining restaurants though the chefs
are hella hands-on oh yeah sauce you
know that dropped on the floor and he
put it back on so that sauce thing he
was handling the handle with that he was
handling the raw chicken with the fried
and he also he also dropped a piece and
threw it back in so it's just so many
disgusting guys so gross yeah it's
pretty nasty
that's disgusting but when you go eat
fast food you gotta know what's coming
but that shouldn't be the standard you
shouldn't be you shouldn't be okay with
that behavior but that's fast food I
understand that but just because it's
happening doesn't mean we can't just
change it so but then you're changing it
to fine dining don't say that my friend
worked at another location of one of
these fast-food restaurants and he says
that when he gets mad in a hot summer
day
he wipes his ball sweat rubs it with his
[ __ ] caddy and says [ __ ] you you
[ __ ] customer and he gives it that's
what's up people that handle food also
handle I can deal with the customers no
he just yeah yeah well sometimes they're
the drive-through customer they hear it
and then they're just yeah I mean I I've
worked like when I used to work in a
restaurant before I've talked to a lot
of people are like no matter how bad you
piss us off we don't [ __ ] with your food
like that's just low I never seen that
at a restaurant but I've seen other
people do it at the restaurant Sarika
he's awesome message [ __ ] yeah it's
dirty but they weren't trying to do
things to [ __ ] with people it was just
like they got a go they're too busy like
[ __ ] I I ran out of plates what am I
gonna do I don't have time to throw it
in the wash the dishwasher there's no
soap we ran out of soap spray it down
real quick wipe it give it to him yeah
and it's kind of like sometimes people
go oh I need another Fork [ __ ] we don't
have any Forks just use that one spray
it give it to him but it sounded like
out of maliciousness ones out of
maliciousness that's [ __ ] low dude
like you are ingesting this [ __ ] and
it's like it's not we're making it like
more fine-dining this as basic human
I think that was a joke yeah I'm saying
like this is basic like some people are
like expect it I wouldn't expect it this
is a good rose humane but when I go to a
fast food
I imagine the buns is a roach mattress
the [ __ ] fungus and you're on the
toilet hating your life I'm gonna not
help you like hey remember your little
[ __ ] I never get fungus from fast food
what fungus man for explosive diarrhea
like stuff like that I've never had a
tummy ache or anything bad from the past
people exactly see the roaches keep it
clean
the headquarters ended up responding to
it and saying that that this person will
need to take certain food safety
training which apparently he had never
taken before and so it's not true basic
knowledge I know a franchisee and never
take that apparent leave here because
that's what happened with this dude he
had never taken the food safety training
have you go what taking food safety
training no but we're not we're not the
actual franchisee we're partners yeah in
a few companies yeah that that's service
food but the people that do it they have
to go to that school I think I try to
[ __ ] delicious I think what we should
do is make it legal for people that are
in charge of our food if they are being
messy like that it's okay if the
corporate or bosses come over and
physically beat you I didn't know where
that sentence was going on yeah yeah
it's like hey you use your hands for
barbecue sauce without washing them
let's cut off those hands we use your oh
I can't stop thinking about the mmm
music video I think like Slim Shady
where he likes Pat and his woman's like
french fries and I was like all goopy
and stuff and then when she walked away
she just ate a fry and like it was
delicious I was like
so looking growth I can't stop thinking
that in my head right now it's probably
happened I've always wanted to own a
business just so I can chew up [ __ ]
people work at the DMV hey guys would
you think of that video I know you loved
it so make sure to hit that like button
to watch more videos check it out up
here
[Music]
[Applause]